olga à les imiter mont-blanc regard une
minute pour casser les pastèques alors
elle se fait un petit est là elle a ses
petites habitudes regard aussi sortie
pique-niqué
si vous nous rejoignez et sachez que le
gabon j'ai également cinq fruits et
légumes par un voilà alors le gars tu te
mets en place ma chérie donc je trouve
que la photo vous douté au double choc
it's ok which took edmundston
photovoltaïque ne voit clair tout ce
passe à thierry moreau oui ah oui vous
parle qu'on m'a demandé de sortir oui ça
va être votre défi dans un mois là vous
allez devoir casser des noix de cajou
avec votre attention
olga est ce que vous êtes prêtre on va
faire le défi de le gall juste après et
nora et isabelle se mettront en place
l'été à olga c'est bon merci tu veux que
je sens et castex finances est bon
attention le gars mettez-vous en place
une minute on à mouloud as d'accord olga
alesi et nohra le frapperait vous
inquiétez pas vous allez avoir le temps
et nous regardent et olga regarder on
regarde vers le gazole et qui fixe à
banache v n va lors olga attention en
une minute combien va-t-elle cassé deux
places tech avec ses cuisses il rata
sextape plus tard c'est vrai c'est parti
olga gérard bien savoir comment lieu
voit comment il veut lui est venue
l'idée
attention c'est parti une minute
j'opte pour le gard
oui on donne pas un chacun peut vous
dire je suis pas à ses programmes
d'armes à la libye où tout est plus en
retrait est allé à sa guise à nice ah
oui ah oui à la cuisse je connais
l'enseigné a relevé la voile ukrainienne
moi je lui ai fait avec des abricots et
les regards et ce qu'elle a ma gueule
la pastèque aller est ce qu'on peut voir
le chrono oui c'est saïd leylaz 24
secondes à les regards alonso kaka à
léogâne 3 pts 2 aïe aïe aïe ça glisse en
un clé de la poste et glissante à l'aube
à troyes pastèque et les attentions
[Applaudissements]
pas de ta krabei merci aux jeunes ne le
gagnera le cap à des brugeois vous
inquiétez pas on va récupérer la peau
c'est qu'on en aura tout public au
chroniqueur ah bah oui
non mais c'est rien ça n'a pas été
touché l'intérieur n'a pas été touché
voilà je regardais moi je crois quand
même en gare à la à la casse et 4 passes
avec premier venu il ya quand même une
énorme rigolade ya quand même un gars
qui va rentrer chez elle en ukraine le
mcee staff et il ya d'ailleurs je suis
parti c'est à une heure du matin car
c'est des pastèques et je préfère les
voilà sur un plateau mais là je suis de
retour
enora et isabelle ribas mais les
premiers de sa copine que son amant
ouais merci je suis avec la vieille dame
faire craquer c'est marius des bonzes il
alors attention
isabelle et nora vous allez vous mettre
en place dans un instant vous allez
devoir battre 4 pastèque cassé en une
minute c'est faisable
alors elle veut revoir vos portes car
s'il vous plaît parce que vous avez tous
parier pour olga sauf une personne c'est
isabelle morini-bosc très attention
réponse dans une semaine on se retrouve
juste après les séries à toutes les
chaînes
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les chéris
nous sommes dans direct
et les enfants pendant toute la vie des
chefs tout le public est là qu il
rappelle les parties sensibles zus
merci il nous reste encore pas mal de
choses à faire dans cette émission de
faire passer un bon moment avec nous on
est là pour vous accompagner toute la
nuit on est bien il est minuit 58
maintenant 00h58 dans un instant on
pourra fêter donc une heure du matin ça
fait combien d'heures de 14 heures à 11
heures 11 heures d'antenne en direct
dont elle aura dans quelques dates en
onze mille euros pour l'association
c'est que du bonheur si vous nous
rejoignez sachez que la personne qui est
derrière moi c'est le gast une amie une
amie craignent haine qui vient et qui
cassent des pastèques entre ses cuisses
c'est sa passion c'est sa vie elle a
deux passions dans la vie
casser des pastèques avec ses cuisses et
faire du frisbee mais elle a plus
occasion d'acheter des pastèques
merci aux gars d'être là je te préviens
l'instant olga a cassé quatre pastèque
entre ses cuisses en une minute thierry
moreau nous a rejoints voilà on n'avait
pas vu vous serez le prochain défi
thierry moreau et thierry moreau dans un
instant vous serez donc vous êtes donc
en poule et vous serez opposé un chien
oui thierry moreau face à un chien c'est
albert le chien vous verrez ce que
voudrait faire respirer
vous avez très chaud donc installé voûte
correctement dit pas rire et dans un
instant entre albert le chien et thierry
mon thé normal tout à l'heure les becs
bon il ya des bugs qui sont là pour
écarter des slips j'ai joué contre un
chien mais où exactement et n'aura pas
donc cassé des pastèques avec isabelle
morini bosc qui va lui venir en aide
alors enora vous allez être donc balancé
par isabelle morini-bosc vous allez
devoir kas est donc le maximum de
pastèque en une minute
ida le score dans le gabarit c4 pastèque
leonora vous prenez les pastèques vous
les placez vous mêmes effets attention
c'est parti une minute on y va on lie à
madaba la manger après donc on essaie on
essaie on reste maîtres de la pastèque
on respecte il nous reste 46 secondes on
est bien on est bien
[Musique]
allez ouais ilike ou lala 3 pastèque
attention je rappelle que tout le monde
à parier pour le ghana dont on a souvent
à parier pour le gaz sont soumises à
belmont nibali ouais ouais ouais 85 vous
êtes égalité vous êtes égalité attention
4 pastèque
non non non à sa guise et attention il
vous reste convaincant s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît c'est de la voir
non non non non aux instances et égalité
des droits dans les appels d'offres à
bagnols
merci aux gars merci merci au canada
la pauvre gars c'était plus dur à quai
on va récupérer les pastèques avance
qu'elles sont bien et on a plein de
pastèques combat on va en servir à tout
public d'accord les chéris merci entre
les récupérer et on le garde
merci d'avoir est avec nous sutout
vaches passive asma si bas voilà elle
est restée passive à qui veut dire bien
sûr pas si bas remonte un peu merci
il ya un grand jeu quand je donne cinq à
gagner abo c'est vrai que vous avez
gagné vous on va revenir sur l'histoire
bravo il aura bravo isabelle vous aviez
vous aviez déjà cassé des pastèques
non mais alors je vais faire tous les
dimanches à lyon les verts souhaitent
saisir je crois pas là et j'ai cassé
plein de trucs un de mes cuisses n'est
pas du passé
moi je vous adore même si ça fait sept
ans vous me casser les bonbons
il ya donc le grand jeu des 35 heures et
oui plus de 20000 euros de cadeaux à
gagner les shihri plein de cadeaux et
surtout de magnifiques week-end dans un
célèbre casinos et hôtels de france
d'accord les cherry pour participer vous
répondez à la question suivante quels
fruits olga at-elle écrasé entre ses
cuisses des pastèques ou des cerises et
à ses bons envoyés baba à par sms au 7
38 38 vous appelez le 39 27 les chéris
d'accord voilà et vous gagnez un
magnifique cadeau un séjour dans un
hôtel
thierry moreau ça va être vous le
prochain défilé oui thierry moreau venez
me rejoindre
venez nous rejoindre vous mettrez votre
masque après eh oui à l'occasion de
votre défi de ce soir thierry moreau les
téléspectateurs vont en apprendre un peu
plus sur votre vie et également sur
votre double puisque oui on part tout de
suite en immersion chez thierry moreau
et on va découvrir votre adversaire
juste après garde mon retour maintenant
pourquoi maintenant bonjour bienvenue
chez moi
au royaume des poules
la journée je suis chroniqueur atp mp
est journaliste et le soir je suis poule
parce que j'aime les poules 1 poule et à
propos j'en ai trouvé une nouvelle
monsieur et madame des fontes un fils
john john duff
or on voit ce soir je vais affronter un
adversaire pour casser des oeufs poules
heureusement mes poules vont entraîner
mes poules m'ont aidé et donc je vais
gagner contre cet adversaire beaucoup
[Musique]
oh
ayew
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez compris vous ne rêvez pas
thierry va affronter un jack russel un
peu spécial et oui thierry albert vont
avoir tout les 2 50 ballons à éclater
qui va éclater le plus vite tous les
ballons thierry moreau avec son bec ou
albert avec ses crocs je vous rappelle
qu'un pari remporté vous fait gagner 5 -
d'ailleurs j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
petit point sur les squales parce que il
n'aura isabelle ont marqué cinq points
il ya un instant un biscuit et n'aura
remporté son défi qu isabelle morini
bosc a bien parier puisqu'elle a parié
sur une loi on va faire ça à planter
voilà on aura donc les sports une
période pour le moment je vais les votes
qui votent pour thierry moreau avec son
bec ou albert le jack russel qui va
éclater le premier 50 balles alors mona
réponse à thierry champion frais
chroniqueur champions en poche
chroniqueur c'est assez partagés syrien
se maintient le chien il ya plus de
chiens que deux chroniqueurs mais bien
les chéris fait entrer thierry fis et
albert thierry albert mettez vos places
puisque votre canard l'appréhendé pas
comment de déclarer ma ruelle
il ya l'air endormi la sarbacane après
rome alors attention les cherry à mon
top vous allez partir celui à lherm
entre eux et moi ne s'est pas le même
que dans le film non sur sa jambe pour
lui il fait le réveiller oui c'est pas
le même c'est son grand-père ou la ville
est la deuxième en changer les
chroniqueurs mais j'adore aller d'un
chien klebba d'accord il ya donc un
chien ouais ouais ouais alors c'est un
champion lui mais il veut plus des
ballons là hélas en quatre ans le géant
qu'est ce qu'il a et attention attention
alors attention
oui 3 2 ap le top
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui regardez
au quart d'heure de jeu chez les 35
heures pour les valenciennois avaient
sciemment allez sortez le
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo bon ben voilà c'est le directeur
allez allez je te répondrais g20 chier
j'espère que j'ai pas à chier
[Applaudissements]
franchement thierry moreau il est un
brave ou non et le chien est un petit
peu stressé oui c'est normal ce n'est
pas normal
si rien c'est que du cacao est ce que ça
représente dans une société comme la
nôtre
les gens lui bien jean-luc je pense
qu'avec cette émission vous pouvez avoir
tendu la garde à terre voilà c'est pas
la bla du caca sous la porte c'est pas
grave ça pour les preuves de leur beau
frère c'est rien du tout c'est rien du
tout les chéris nous sommes en mesure de
faire un point sur les scores et oui il
est 1h 20 et on a enfin les scores de
cette émission les chérit les scores ils
sont là ils sont ici benjamin castaldi
va pas les cherry pour l'instant c'est
madame un qui gagne son billet pour le
ski et sébastien cauet et jean-luc pour
l'instant il y as match pour le réveil
je vous l'avais dit oui mais j'avais dix
points refaites les comtés ont au moins
gagné 3 donc je peux pas avoir 10 m à
6,6 nourdine qu'en régie on a poussé à
l'appel trois là j'ai gagné sur le gain
sur le chien et toi j'ai gagné
maintenant bassij et bizet pour le
chroniqueur ben j'ai gagné et pareil
vous avez changé votre poker a produit
ils savaient pas du lundiau à régis sont
claires si nette est proche de 25 ans tu
as dit après avoir vu le jeu vous avez
dit mon chauffeur vu le jr l'échangé
carnage
richer pour l'instant même s'il vous
plaît vous lis et j'avais le chien donc
enfin j'avais refaites les contre brett
l'émission elles le font même s'il faut
qu'on essaie score à 4 heures du matin
on les aura quand on voit la balle a pas
d'accord en tout cas ce qui est sûr et
certain c'est que benjamin au prince est
oui mais moi j'aime ça c'est sûr oui
mais ne met pas premier pour moi voilà
n'être ni premier ni dernier vous êtes
dans le ventre mou est une merde comme
en voit là bas mais demain je vais me le
prendre dans la gueule 1
ça va mon chéri à 10 attendez avant de
voir le bisou je vois qu'ils les
messages qu'il a reçus
rien ici à rien aucun message n'en suis
pas très rapide dans le parisien bien
l'appareil
et qu'aucun changement et je referai pas
sain fait des articles j'en ai rien à f
bon les cherry bomb à tous de passer un
prochain happening et justement c'est
mon matthieu delormeau noaa
on va jouer au palais des fesses sais
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mathieu shader à voir
[Rires]
[Musique]
bassano maty gbané normatif chic mais tu
au courant du défi non non c'est vrai
ben ça alors ça c'est comme résumé non
pas du tout pour vous affronter
je vous demande d'accueillir celle qu'on
appelle tous souplesse elle s'appelle
noémie mais dans le monde et dans le
métier on l'appelle souplesse
applaudissements pour elle
les voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là juste noémie vous êtes
championne de toi qu est-ce qu on peut
rappeler ce qu'est le thoër qu est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire une petite
démo ce qu'on peut nous faire une petite
démonstration s'il vous plaît allez on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wahaha indépendante tout seul alors
[Applaudissements]
à la défense habité aux normales comme
vous pouvez le voir c'est une très très
belle discipline
non vraiment un brave aux abonnés on est
près de moi noémie alors est là vous
avez des faits exceptionnels autonome
surtout non mais c'est vrai nom est la
raison elle sa suspension hydraulique
non mais franchement c'est vrai il ya
une vie après vos fesses vraiment en
avant nos amis sachent où travaillent 1
voilà c'est quoi vous faites mais là
dedans beaucoup de danse et ben en tout
cas besoin pas
merci beaucoup de danse beaucoup de
muscu merci et van gogh oui merci
et donc vous êtes beaucoup de danse
beaucoup de muscu beaucoup de danse
beaucoup de miss cuivre bravo en tout
cas c'est très réussi un crochet frappe
c'est autre chose que les pastèques oui
bah elle est là elle arrive à témoin et
opter dépistage je vous le dis comme ça
alors on va faire un défi entre matthieu
delormeau et vous mathieu vous allez
être aidé par gilles verdez c'est très
simple regardez il y à un palais et vous
allez devoir faire vous allez devoir
faire tout un parcours en guidant enfin
non franchement voilà en prenant ce
palais avec vos fesses à ans le montant
est en fait allons en allant jusque là
d'accord ok pour ça qu'on m'a mis
éléments dans le slip j'avais pas
compris tout à l'heure quand vous avez
un livre nous avons des membres si oui
vous allez là depuis combien de temps au
plus deux heures le mât les articles
c'est après les nouilles léman mennella
à 20h on m'a dit tiens mais on m'a mis à
l'honneur que tu l'avais dit rien trois
heures que je l'aï fait trois hommes
c'est pour ça que sur ce fut le message
sur son téléphone un truc qui marche
noémie souplesse va faire le par là et
juste après donc mathieu normes aux
haltères il faut que vous oubliez votre
jeans pour que les membres puissent
passer d'accord y'a pas trop là alors à
votre avis qui va faire le plus
rapidement le parquet les mots si les
morts bravo c'est tout à votre honneur
ce qu'on peut revoir les mots comme ça
pour leur virée pied dément avoir
d'éléments merci à
ouais ouais série les lèvres montes de
plus un c'est l'agent si c'est rien
alors c'est rien alors effectivement et
donc la garde alors là vous allez voir
samedi à 10 heures j'ai offert la démo
garder chez vous c'est plus exister mais
c'est plus excitant que les magnette sur
le frigo
ah oui j'irai sûrement qu à regarder
m mettez-vous en position assise
populaire merci penser aux courses de
demain regardez et la voilà hélas là
comme par enchantement
[Rires]
bravo souplesse bravo cas de ce type
ouverts est ce que le mien fonctionne
non non non je ne sais pas mais c'est
vrai ça n'arrive pas après gilles pour
les faits n'ayez pas peur là mais quand
vous mangez un mois je vais réussir sur
nos ondes
oui ça se veut non non non il ya les co
ok alors mathieu est ce que vous avez
des questions magali et de l'écho mais
qu'ils se plantent dictaphone creux cinq
premiers de la course
attention on respecte mathieu 3d en
direct
il lui a annoncé la police alors qui dit
que dieu que mathieu va gagner le
masters sera guidée par claire d'accord
on est guidé par y regarder il ne voit
pas oui les guider ces moments de vie
des idées ouais je pense souplesse que
vous allez gagner alors souplesse je
vous donne ça ou vous avez déjà le vôtre
à il est déjà d'accord où jésus merci
monsieur souplesse et à vous on va
chronométrés sur le parcours mais tu es
bon tu peux sur le côté pour qu'on
puisse voir souplesse parce que c'est
vrai qu'on attendait ça pendant toute la
soirée
merci à tous et à nous détendre un peu
soupex je vais rester en paca pour que
vous avez un problème
bien entendu je suis là vous n'avez qu'à
mme sow n'est d'accord merci souplesse
souplesse c'est à vous top chrono
on y va
[Musique]
voilà par la même chose
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aucun des mains voila rouges à croix
ça passe très bien
[Musique]
moi j'ai trois 3 3
gaillard c'est mieux que ça dure plus
longtemps
j'ai pas longtemps et demain
[Musique]
souplesse attendait continuer oui alors
attendez-vous prince quand on a une
minute 0 2 nous on ne s'en lasse pas
donc un succès perdure à l'énoncé pas
perdu pour moi souplesse vous voulez que
je vous ai de quelques manières que ce
soit trop hâte rôle d'un agent fois quoi
oui c'est à dire jamais pu le prendre là
souplesse dont 14 pour souplesse venez
vous détendre un petit peu ma table pour
moi c'est clair attention à bâle on va
passer du rêve au cauchemar
là c'est matthieu delormeau et c'est là
qu'on souhaite qu'il le fasse en 20
secondes
ah oui la wii note matthieu delormeau
qui est guidé par gilles verdez gilles
attention elle ne criait pas trop mais
temps vous si le fun quand m vous
devriez vous allongez ici pour les y
aider
voilà vous avez avoir une belle but
c'est l'arrière train sifflera trois
fois là attention que rich guide 3 2 un
top
les blocs eu droit un rêve le plus fou
du roi tout droit lève encore les mots
forts pour la corde à droite - superbe
conte bientôt peniket la horizontale
mais pourquoi des banques oui oui pas
doucement continue et mathieu sur la
même ligne les ventes ont lieu qu un
tout petit peu le cul lève le cube les
gens pour le voilà à droite
c'est génial vanille continue facebook
ou à froid comme 3m
trois factions elle est allée un peu
trop à droite
super mario et maman tu remonte sur
spillane car j'ai fait ce qu olivia
bouler qui fait ce pôle et la c3 bon
teint pour le bassin donc le bassin
montez le bassin montre le bassin
hongrois la à droite mathieu tu super à
droite mathieu à la baisse les fesses
baisse les faits mais les restes way we
made you tube est du belge et du tout un
endroit si tu mama oui monsieur bowie
à
matthieu brabant mathieu la bonne humeur
des sarthois conduisent à des impasses
il ay l'aïd et mathieu y menait ainsi
avait il avait visé merci bravo m'a tuer
mais vous faites des choses avec vos
fesses non mais non je ne crois pas de
personnel et votez pour moi je nomme je
sais m'en servir et merci à gilles qui a
été incroyable alors il ya souplesse qui
dit je crois que c'est une invitation
ça fait plusieurs invitations qui me
donne et malheureusement je n'y suis je
n'ai jamais répondu par un pain par la
positive voilà est-ce que vous voulez
faire un petit bisou à jean-michel même
parce qu'il a pris une banane tout à
l'heure ah bon merci à ben voila et ben
voila vous voyez et ses hauts et bas à
la whey bout je suis votre paul pogba
reims et que des pâtes l'essence le gaz
sans décoller c'est un truc toute la
journée juppé des passes décisives lot
il a plus qu'à mettre la tête baba alla
merci eux vous rhabiller gentiment oui
merci viau q eh bien je voudrais
remercier souplesse d'avoir été avec
nous fait état d'un mort
toute la spéciale et tous et bravo à
mathieu de leur moral ouais
cherry et pas les bras mecheri avant
d'avoir une énorme surprise sont
vraiment et si vous pouvez ne vous
couchez pas maintenant parce que dans un
instant je vous le dis on jouera à qui
sera le meilleur couple on fera des
amours très spécial ici sur ce plateau
je vous dis on aura des invités de folie
des invités de folie je suis même à deux
doigts je vais demander en régie est ce
qu'on peut pas le laisser pour demain
pour le prime parce que on a beaucoup de
choses à faire mais non on peut pas ils
peuvent quoi alors l'abonnement est en
veille alors allez paris chéri 1 et on
vous dira dans un instant pour le moment
on va s'intéresser à deux poids lourds
du paf
là vraiment on a deux gars c'est la
ligue des champions de l'animation va
pas se mentir
cauet benjamin castaldi et c'est à dieu
est un petit peu spécial puisqu'il va
opposer
cauet à benjamin cauet vous avez perdu
17 kilos
vous avez un corps de rêve non non non
non non non non non si vous faites de la
musculation comme une fois par semaine
j'ai commencé a pas longtemps mais
combien le tous les matins demi-heure
une heure benjamin moi je fais trois
heures de boxe par semaine
d'accord ça sèche s'assèche taccone la
seiche
[Rires]
on a une bande de copains attention quoi
attention attention et on l'écouté des
chroniqueurs moi je peux me prendre des
armes et nous respectent très très bien
comment est ce qu'on raconte ils nous
respectent très très bavard et a eu
comme c'est un amour celui-ci vous voyez
un comme toi
tout le monde est fatigué tout le monde
dit des conneries comme on dit n'importe
quoi alors le shérif deux poils de
l'animation vont s'affronter
on vous a prévu un duel exceptionnel
vous allez doit faire des tractions un
petit peu spécial ça va arriver c'est
pas prêt je mets ça va arriver dans un
instant c'est très simple vous allez
devoir faire des tractions
je vous le dis et vous allez devoir
gober des bananes en faisant des
tractions et ben en entière non ce que
vous pouvez celui qui donnera le plus de
bananes en un minimum de temps gagnera
le duel il faut parier entre coco et
benjamin comme un hommage à maldini
alors à votre avis qui qui va faire
d'ailleurs je propose que notre en ford
en un instant matthieu delormeau nous
fasse une petite démo c'est un oui lui
le son prix soit en fait pas des
tractions non moi je te pète la gueule
au monde
entre un goût amer à l'algérie regardez
plutôt qu elle est votée ne s'est pas tu
regardes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] mais non mais je commence à me
faire chier on voit et ça continue
double xl moi le truc à moi ça mais je
mets plus du double xl jamais mis du de
plus elle vous vite fait une fois
maintenant l'habitude veut rester comme
ça pour le risque et c'est en fait
c'était l'ancienne fringues mais tout va
très bien
ouais ouais ouais ça y est vous avez vu
comment il est devenu beau son économie
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des cendres c'est mon propre
blog bien népal et en asie s'établissant
à bien ses plans et ses parties droite
bush fils moi allons tourner non ici le
bus man que j'étais fauché d'antan mois
à la wii compact la benjamin les cherry
est ce que l'installation est prête s'il
vous plaît est ce qu'on peut voilà si
vous plairont pas ouvrir et vous allez
voter
benjamin ou sébastien du filet champions
qui le chroniqueur à l'oreille à oui
c'est vrai ça on a oublié des pancartes
on va dire eh bien on va dire
franchement leur dis tous à l'oral mais
vous viendrez de tout bon moi je mise
sur benjamin ben hadj amar et nora
sishuba j'avance bayonne 1 isabelle
benjamin benjamin benjamin benjamin moi
jamais jean le gall n'est pas du tout
concerné par la mer jamais je n'ai
encore pas dans ces dix ans un matthieu
delormeau
non vraiment j'aime les deux mais
j'avoue qu'au comment peut-être un peu
de technique là-dessus jr benjamin elle
sans déconner c'est pas évident du fait
très très chaud mais qui peut pouvoir en
plus c'était banal au dessus il faut
monter et prendre la balade
la demande reste accroché à chaque fois
ah ouais à la bourre descends descends
ouais c'est que là c'est chaud quand
même d'accord avec cauet meilleur sur
les bananes des benjamins son attraction
ouais attention parce que la lourdeur
vous êtes numéro un à me lasser vous
pouvez voler des codes barres est ce que
mathieu voulait faire une petite démo
justement voilà gobain est ce qu on a
droit comme ça oui bien sûr d'accord
attention c'est une distraction non mais
pas celle du milieu manceau
elles devront regarder elle est bien
mûre voilà la waho pas bah voilà la
saison et après on va dire que c'est moi
qui le qui le traite mal
alors oui c'est un plus on va y aller
les chercher on va voir triompher le
plus
on va démarrer on va démarrer par
benjamin castaldi d'accord benjamin
castaldi petite traction voyez c'est là
et vous aller choper la malade a il met
des gants et où on m'a donné des gants
attention on va voir combien de temps
faut jusqu'au quai la bananeraie vous
l'apprenez mais on veut la recracher
après ça tu emploies parce que celle-ci
voilà est-ce qu'on peut avoir quelqu'un
qui peut oui oui bon faites comme vous
voulez vous me la donnez enfin vouloir
donner à quelqu'un qu'on sait attention
c'est parti
oui oui c'est bon c'est bon et c'est
juste la banane séchée
ouais c'est leur attention j'ai apprécié
que ça bouge benmoussa thomas mc saïda
qui est sûr je peux pas en faire
bravo madame ouais si on perd oui madame
un super bon tir mais là il va se tuer
et me faire mal mais vous y arrivez
ouais bien beau jeune homme allait
s'allier dernière balade
oui toi moi bachelot 19h au bon moment
exceptionnel benjamin stora leonard
bravo bravo mon badge inrap d'alix et
long benjamin castadi qu coco je le sors
atraco qu il démarre la muscu nasa fait
pas et ça fait un mois et demi super
sympa alors je le sens pas du tout à en
plus il a les chinois l'alm 1 alors vous
c'est pas la peine de mettre la voilà
vous n'avez pas aller chez le malade
juste vous faites les tractions avant ça
il est allé chez avon ah bah non alors
oui bah oui une banane d'or est une
ballade éliminé je vous le rappelle
comme vous le savez il ya pas de joker
on peut pas voir rien non attention ces
bons ne changeait pas les malades
regardez les on va distribuer n'est pas
notre rôle à plein de fruits ouais mais
je peux pas le plein de fruits
ça va mon coco non benjamin castaldi
attention battant bastia mais comme je
n'ai jamais vu autant ratera tiens tiens
au bout de ma vie
c'est la clé de mon coeur il est clair
comme ça où comme ça je peux te la
[ __ ] au cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
barnaby 12e
allez mon coco tout le monde va voir non
mais c'est pas grave
et tu as tu as un pied très beau web et
non mais vraiment je te le dis tu encore
la magnifique album va savoir mme heloir
2 1
oui bon chocolat ouais ouais ouais mon
coco m'a dit ça passe sa paroisse sanaa
quatre oui ça parce qu'on attendait et
la dernière non alors là c'est fini
c est quand même pas mal
un gars c'est pas grave qu'elles
évacuent la shoah bravo monsieur
réussite planète était au top le n 1
concombre ah ben voilà peu dire votre
peau à peau lisse la peau les efforts et
c'est pas mal
allez mon hiver bien non mais
franchement c'est qu'il ya plein fouet
attendez les jeunes esprits de compet
d'un coquet rentrer dans moi m haies et
aux coutumes a impressionné oui moi
aussi je te penches alors voilà je le
sentais bien
il est très fort entre action et un peu
moins fort au coup de poing marquardt a
invité la revanche j'y arrive pas puis
après derrière il a ce fait il a été
avec soin il est très bon et
agrandissements pour benjamin coin voilà
avant les faits elle en benjamins kagame
oui j'avais oublié qu'ils avaient encore
ça et oui c'est le défi de valérie
benaïm aux dames attend dé lui déguisé
en poule et moi j'ai un truc à eux tu
vas bien ouais alors non valérie s'est
pas du tout croyant son truc notre
valérie ma chérie est ce que vous pouvez
venir me rejoindre et bien sûr valérie
bénaïm pour sonder et après il y aura le
défi de jean luc et ce sera le dernier
défi d'asseoir et moi j'aurai un petit
défi contre quelqu'un en tout cas et
bravo les chéris attention comment ça va
le vélo mon chéri romain est un gars on
regarde ça fait quand même
ça va faire mais ça va faire 12 heures
qu'ils pédalent le vercors il est là un
moule et les prix joueurs ça fait douze
heures qui [ __ ] il me suit partout où
je paye ses intrigues
c'est un truc de malade non mais sans
déconner moi je [ __ ] pendant 20
minutes près on dirait que j'ai fait le
lot le mont blanc alors valérie bénaïm
vous êtes connu pour être une animatrice
formidable c'est également pour avoir un
bloc santé beauté boulette sbbl santé
beauté boulette ce soir vous allez
pouvoir nous montrer vos talents de
maquilleuses démaquille asie de
maquilleuses et on va même découvrir que
vous avez fait une pub vous avez fait
une pub
oui ben ouais non c'est vrai oui pour
touche pas à mon poste pas pour nous
quoi pourquoi ici valérie bénaïm
regarder votre duel
[Musique]
ce soir c'est le combat des chefs
la chef des chefs c'est bon je sais
farmiga d'alan fatale active
indépendante mais je suis une femme à
tout
moi je suis un peu léonard de vinci du
make-up mon pinceau c'est mon eyeliner
je suis un chef-d'oeuvre
je suis mona lisa valérie bénaïm cv
c'est terrible et des fonds c'est sûr je
paye à nice tu erres
[Musique]
non
allez
eh oui
valérie vous allez affronter une
maquilleuse professionnelle vous allez
affronter bilitis qu'elle apprenait voir
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là très jolie bimbo 13 les
compères cette maquilleuse
professionnelle c'est ça donc vous
maquille vodafone a maquillé
professionnellement c'est à dire pas aux
amateurs n'ont pas de point soleil
phréatique qui est le mieux maquiller
ici enora et nora est très bien aussi
sympa ce petit rouge d'armes ce qui je
mets bien tenu en chine
merci c'est très joli c'est gentil mais
vous allez affronter benhaim est
également jolie rien hélas la boulette
de voir ça
mais qu'est ce que je dois faire en fait
bâcher vous dire ce que vous allez faire
valérie vous allez devoir vous maquiller
et bilitis vaille à maquiller isabelle
morini-bosc maintien oui quelle surprise
elle va vous maquiller les yeux bandés
elle va maquiller isabelle morini-bosc
les yeux bandés et vous galérez venez
vous maquillez souvent dans la voiture
et bien vous allez faire comme
d'habitude vous allez vous maquiller
dans la voiture elle allait rentrer dans
cette voiture et vous maquiller et
qu'est ce qu'elle à l'avenant mais la
voiture a bien tourné
elle tourne un peu au sérieux quoi vous
inquiétez pas ce sera trente secondes la
mieux ma quille au mât qui allait y perd
également on va dire 45 sur balles et a
les yeux bandés et vous vous êtes dans
la voiture mais vous voyez bien à bâtir
elle fait des tonneaux et alors rien du
tout les tonneaux attendait tout le
monde a fait des tonneaux une fois dans
sa vie il a arrêté
oui c'est bon on n'est pas à ça près on
se bat il est l'idée 13h50
on sait la vie quoi car et bilitis va
maquiller les yeux bandés à votre avis
qui va le mieux maquiller qui sera la
meilleure maquilleuse valérie bénaïm et
bilitis championne donc bilitis bilitis
bilitis bilic sam à l'égard des libanais
lambert et la mâche et bisous tout le
monde vote contre vous valérie benaïm et
tout le monde vote pour bilitis je vais
demander isabelle morini-bosc verrou la
série narre à son tonneau comme sa fin
mais excusez moi euh ça va vous sinon au
niveau de l'humour mère s'est installée
vous mâcher installez-vous bilitis
installez-vous bravo bilitis est un dieu
bénisse et on y va on va de la voiture
valérie bénaïm on flippe à 4 et là c'est
très bon délire très bon délire de
fléchi mais qui est bilitis dieu bénisse
son fessier bravo si vous avez pensé
mais parlez pas de vous il parlait pas
de vous parlez pas de vous parlez pas
vous inquiétez pas
valérie bénaïm vous me dites comme le
prêtre ça ne risquons rien pour valérie
bénaïm en régie on n'est pas sûr puisque
nous sommes en dernier n'est pas sûr on
n'a pas testé tout va bien c'est
sécurisé vous inquiétez pas valérie au
pire des cas voilà ou pire des cas juste
cette attention valérie de ne pas vous
éborgné avec le maquillage d'accord ma
chérie ne prenait pas de risques 1 le
prenez pas tous les risques pour cette
émission elle adore ma chérie oui je
sais que vous prenez tous les risques
pour votre carrière
mais pour une fois levé le pied
attention que vous avez tous parier pour
bilitis est-ce que vous êtes prêts jésus
elle est prête
ouais alami est là à la misa ceinture
ces mois-là mis sa ceinture monter la
ceinture à valérie daunas attention
bilitis mettez votre bandeau sur les
yeux et vous allez donc maquiller
isabelle morini-bosc les yeux bandés on
verra dans un instant des résultats qui
sera la mieux maquiller autres valérie
bénaïm et isabelle morini-bosc déjà
isabelle parent cas petit avantage vous
est magnifiquement maquiller moi je
voulais vous le dire
aller et on est il alors 50 on dit
n'importe quoi on les bat on fait
plusieurs agents on les bat alors
attention ce que vous êtes prêt de
valérie way est ce que vous êtes prêts
pittis au max et dieu bénisse le fessier
on les bat top c'est parti
oui mais formule mais c'est valérie
j'entends ça va mal et vous maquillez
valérie ne pensait qu'au maquillage
valérie
voilà à hausser nourriture en simple à
l'évidence une beauté bon c'est voter
quand vous sortirez de sa voiture
peut-être que partage vous verra vers lé
bas du battage vous attendra à valérie
mettez du rouge à lèvres vallée leila
valérie on aime bien l'air il nous reste
plus de trente secondes on a fait la
moitié du parcours
il y séjournera qu'ils avaient le niveau
là bien qu'elle ait pas besoin d'être
chaussé mi journée le taux directeur est
chéri et tout se passe très bien terne
en direct et vous êtes très très
nombreux à nous regarder ce soir jeudi
au honduras
alors attention la baie c'est cinq
cadres à eux
[Musique]
alors on va tout de suite voir le
maquillage d'isabelle morini-bosc par
bility foutait de ma gueule
on n'a rien fait j'étais de la mienne
alors là oui j'avais un stade vide en
lorraine on dirait la schtroumpfette
ben voilà pourquoi c'est tout ce que
vous avez fait l'ombre à paupières le
petit trait de liner yeux rouges à
lèvres ouais d'accord alors venez avec
nous avec moi venez avec moi bilitis
également même et d'urbanisme pour le
fessier sioniste merci valérie bénaïm va
arriver on va voir ses maquillages et
valérie qui elle a créé un véritable à
valérie elle a bien géré et on va dire
c'est moi qui vais désigner le grand
gagnant moussavou pas très bien les yeux
comme ça parce que vous avez quel lieu
de quelle couleur gris gris à gris bleu
gris ah oui comme je me suis sorti
pendant trois ans avec un garçon sans
qu'ils se rendent compte que j'avais les
yeux bleus je pensais qu'il était temps
de mettre un terme d'accords sûr vous me
permettez vous me permettez à 1h55 vous
dire c'est une très belle avec nos tête
à salou m haies et prime-1 et regarder
pédaler
j'aime ma patrie qui y est tout le temps
avec ça et je n'ai jamais aussi belle
mais vous êtes radieux c'est l'état dans
la salle de mort moi ces balles et rim
et nike a gagné a perdu un bras bandé
ici merci papa dans le garage maintenant
j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on
applaudisse traitement valérie benaïm
qui a eu le courage bravo bravo isabelle
morini-bosc cette très belle aussi
c'est quand même binetti cinquième d'une
oie et dieu bénisse pour le fessier
bravo à nice